[Music]  Mila Kunis transforms into a blonde  bombshell thank you  the 34 year old actress was spotted on  set in Germany Tuesday rocking a much  lighter hue while filming her latest  movie right my bed spoiler alert  Mila didn't actually dye her hair those  white blonde tresses are just a wig but  she stunned all the same pairing the  look with a formal lavender gown and  black suit jacket we did it Neela's  transformation is all for her latest  role in the spy who dumped me she  co-stars alongside Saturday Night Live  funny gal Kate McKinnon the 33 year old  comedian actually swapped looks to  trading in her signature blonde tresses  for this curly brown do while the action  comedy doesn't hit theaters until next  July that's not okay  you can catch Mila sooner I feel like a  giant stress ball from like November to  New Year's in a bad mom's Christmas out  November 3rd Christmas  [Music]  Oh